coming in white hair coming in green
genevieve and clowney coming to
cleveland on a one-year deal last year
they wanted him
on a three-year deal that was worth like
somewhere between 50 and 60 million
he didn't want that deal now he does the
one-year deal worth
up to 10 million which means it's worth
less
than 10 million to do certain things
and you never know until you see the
incentive package sometimes you
literally have to be the super bowl mvp
to get your full amount maybe he's got
to be defensive player of the year he
talked about that yesterday
but uh chris we saw this coming it was
his second visit to cleveland
i'm surprised they did it before the
draft what if they have some guy
fall to them that's their highest rated
pass rusher and he just happens to be
there
and they've given this contract to
jadavian clowning maybe they still take
the guy i don't know
but i thought they'd wait until after
the draft to go after damian clown
well i think it gives them a little
flexibility in the draft and i think
where they're sitting
probably there in the 20s they're
probably looking at it like
huh that's dicey difference making
pass rusher territory i'm not sure if
there's going to be that type of guy
there in this draft
so i think that's probably where that
that thought comes in mike
at least as far as not you know
exhausting the draft for that position
but
man clowney nonetheless with this
defense opposite of miles garrett man
you got two number one picks two of the
freakier guys
in the nfl that we've seen in the league
over the last 15 years or so
as far as size speed the way they can
change directions do all those things
and of course it makes sense like we
talked a little bit yesterday because of
the scheme fit
and everything like that life's going to
be simple for should gideon county get
wide rush the pastor do all that you
know nice move by cleveland you're right
they probably got to still get some
people
at some point at that position to to
fill it out for depth
but either way we know that the starting
four
sheldon richardson miles garrett and
jedevian that that's pretty legit when
you just say those three names right
there
well miles garrett first round pick
first overall pick in 2017. sheldon
richardson a first round pick of the
jets in 2013.
genivian clowney number one overall pick
in 2014.
tak mckinley a backup in that rotation
pass rusher our first round pick of the
falcons
in 2017 clowney gives them chris
10 first round picks on the roster wow
three number one overall picks
on the roster from 2014 2017 2018 of
course baker mayfield
this browns team is different the browns
is the browns is no longer applicable to
the browns
not with those first round picks that
they have i can't imagine a time
since the browns returned to the nfl in
1999
when they had that much talent that much
now look some of these guys
like mckinley he was available to be
signed because he didn't live up to that
first round status but still
10 first-round picks on the cleveland
browns that would have been
incomprehensible a few years
no it's amazing they've done an
unbelievable job of turning over their
roster and i mean you
you really look at it like you see here
on this graphic i mean forget these
names
i mean there's there's a lot of other
names not on this list that are really
damn good too
and i think when you take into account
even with last year
yeah okay you didn't have a guy like
jodevion county you know some of the
additions they've made in free agency
here
and you know guys like denzel ward were
hurt you know kind of in and out of the
lineup their other starting quarter
greedy williams he wasn't out there
you know the whole year so there there's
guys on the roster already that they're
going to be better with but i think when
you just talk about
clowney and then now they've addressed
the safety position a little bit with
john johnson from the rams
anthony walker at linebacker we talked
about that a bunch of the free agents
at free agency they need a linebacker
well anthony walker's their kind of guy
you just look at their team and their
roster mike and like awful what you said
i mean the browns is the browns or maybe
it's just the browns
are awesome or the browns has got a
really good roster is the real phrase
because you look at it mike and you just
go what's not to like about the way the
team was built right now going into this
season
five years ago yeah i was talking about
whether or not in five years time
the browns would be back and
i actually and i see the envelope all
the time
it's sitting on it's sitting on a
surface downstairs in my office
it says do not open until i think august
16 2021
i called my shot then that the browns
will be regarded as a better
organization than the cowboys in five
years time
so wow premature but not much is going
to change between now and august
right is it fair to say that right now
the browns top to bottom overall are a
better organization
than the dallas cowboys well
yes i mean we know this is a what have
you done for me lately league and where
are we right now
as far as where we're sitting we're
talking about the browns who won a
playoff game
and had the chiefs on the ropes and
could have easily won that football game
if it's not for a bounce of a ball the
certain way and the north korea rule and
all those type of things
so yeah i don't think there's any doubt
about that
you know i you again the the the cowboys
we talked yesterday a little bit about
them
the offense is in a good place there's a
lot to be excited about there
but defensively there's big time issues
you know on that side of the ball so no
i mean i i don't think it's even close i
think the browns are clearly in a better
state right now than the dallas cowboys
now i went through 336 and won
the hugh jackson tenure after see
i i was confident in the browns
when hugh jackson was the head coach so
i'm glad i made it
five years instead of three yeah uh and
the fact that the cowboys continue to
struggle to live up to their potential
makes it a little bit easier but
i i'm going to pop that thing open on
august 16 and i'm going to read whatever
i wrote five years ago and i'm pretty
sure if my memory holds up which
there's a chance it doesn't that that's
exactly what i said apparently we're
going to post a twitter poll and there's
going to be people pete that
think we're nuts for posting the
question because right now the browns
are
the better team it's hard to get used to
the idea
of the browns being i know cowboys but
get used to as you mentioned
clowning and miles garrett teaming up
clowney
was asked about that reality yesterday
here he is a lot has been made about you
pairing up obviously with miles garrett
and that
your arrival will help him how much will
playing with him help you
a lot i've been getting double team off
a lot in this league
my career and uh i'm looking forward to
playing with somebody
dominant on the opposite side like a
mouse gear who can
draw a double team maybe i can go one on
one more
you know the key with judith cloudy
though is this and i wrote this last
night at psft what are the browns
getting with jadavian clowny and it
depends it depends on whether or not
he's healthy and can stay
healthy right and shereen williams added
that on pftpm last
night also motivated i think he's always
motivated
he plays through a lot of stuff and we
don't know it and a lot of these guys
don't wear that on their sleeves they
don't walk around talking about how
banged up they are
right in part because they don't want
anyone targeting whatever part of them
is banged up i think the issue with
clowning
this goes back to i remember his rookie
year he only played in four games that
year he came down
funny on his knee i'm not weird and he's
hurt he's out for the rest of the year
yeah and then he needed micro fracture
surgery bone on bone conditioning his
knee after only one year
it's amazing in many respects that he's
still able to play
no doubt so i i think that it's easy
to to be infatuated with
the film of clowney when he's healthy
and he's racking up the f up the play
stat that we're still trying to get a
live sports bureau to officially
recognize
but he's not going to give you that for
16 games he's played 16 games
once in a seven year career one time
he played in 16 games and my guess is
every year he's always fighting through
something yeah to get on the field every
sunday no
i mean mike i mean you you said it right
i mean first off micro fracture surgery
that's like a career ender for most guys
he's hung in there i think that speaks
to kind of the freak of nature he is
you know as far as athletically in the
build of his body and everything like
that
and even off that mike he's been on my
podcast before
and he said even with that bum knee like
he can't
he can't bend when he's past rushing
because of it he can't put the pressure
on it that he would have been able to
before that injury
so it's affected him but it doesn't
matter but you know like like you're
you're right when he's healthy he's
amazing he's a wrecking ball
he f's plays up everywhere the stats
forget production it's all about
disruption with clowney and
yeah the injury thing is a real thing i
think when you sign a guy like him
the cleveland browns you've got to be
just going wait
we'd love we want we want 10 to 12 games
and we want to be healthy for the
playoffs that's what you got to be
thinking
like and and and the other thing with
clowning just you know to piggyback a
little bit off of the
the question he was asked in the press
conference the cleveland's a great
signing for him
you know just because of the things we
just talked about yeah obviously
you know miles garrett's going to be the
guy that gets the attention he's going
to get one-on-ones
you know the last two teams he's been on
the seahawks and the texans
he's been like the guy the guy
wait wait where's where's clowney
where's clowney there's nobody else on
their defense we gotta worry about
where's he at send the back there chip
him hit the tight end why
you know tight end hit him while he's
being blocked so he's always had the
bull's eye on his back with the last two
defenses he's been on too that doesn't
help your
you know health matters either uh so i
think there's a lot of positives for him
and of course the positives for
cleveland if he can stay healthy
you just look at it it's another
position mike where you go
wow the browns are like towards the top
of the league in that position or that
unit
on their roster and it's pretty damn
impressive that way
we were rolling a highlight package
there of jadavian clowney from last year
most of those plays were from week
one against the denver broncos and
that's going to be the key
chris not getting caught up
in the fascination with what he can do
if he's healthy early in the season
manages practice reps
limit his game snaps and do what you
have to do
to keep him healthy constantly monitor
and keep him healthy
for january forget about september and
october because if you
if you become in awe of what he can do
you throw caution to the wind and you're
not going to have him
when the season's on the line and you're
not gonna have him when you get to the
playoffs and
the the simple fact that we're presuming
playoffs for the browns just shows you
how far they've come
yeah it's not even if it's not even if
no when the browns get to the playoffs
this year they need to have jadavian
clowning healthy
it is stunning how quickly the
perception
has changed of the cleveland browns no
it's amazing it really is and
it's like i feel like you know like like
we just said a few minutes ago we
haven't even seen them at their pinnacle
yet is their
full roster being healthy and everything
like that
that's what's exciting like but like
with the clowny thing too mike take this
into account
it's a guy too who because of his
contract situations
i'm glad he signed right now too because
now you know
get a part of an offseason workout
program hopefully there is some sort of
otas but nonetheless a training camp
he's been treated i mean cheated out of
training camps the last two years
because he was waiting to kind of be
traded from the texans of the seahawks
he got there
late i believe if i remember uh
correctly
and then of course last year he sat on
the sideline until late in training camp
before he finally signed with a football
team
so it's good that it's happening now uh
for sure for the player but like mike
that's what i was talking about with the
browns
i mean you go through it mike right i
mean offensive line
arguably the best in football wide
receivers
you know when healthy i mean that that's
a pretty
special tandem i think they'd be in the
conversation of top five duos in
football right
running back duos i i don't know is
there a better one
i don't think there is you know you talk
about the d-line i know there's the if
of clowney but when you just talk about
the three names we brought up earlier
you go
that's one of the better units in
football i mean there there's four or
five the tight end
play is up there like that i mean so
there's four or five units we've talked
about where you go
they're towards the cream of the crop
and the whole league at their position
unit
and that's why i think we're going
brown's playoffs so we're not even
saying if or whatever else we're just
going yeah it's happening
points bet has the browns at a minus 170
proposition to make the playoffs you got
to bet 170 to win 100 the steelers in
contrast are plus 135.
there probably hasn't been a year in the
last
i don't know 50 where the browns would
have been regarded as a
better chance of making the playoffs
than the steelers but that's kind of
where we are where's the weakness
in the cleveland browns where's the one
thing if you're a browns fan
and you're tempted to count your
chickens
what's the one thing that would have you
concerned about whether or not they're
gonna hatch well i think the
the defense is where you do go maybe
that like again the back
the back unit's a little unproven denzel
ward's showed great promise
you know when he is healthy he's he's
damn good
he really is he's one of the better
corners in football but that's been a
little iffy
you know and then the other corner
position and the safety spots have not
really been solidified
so i think that's the thing we got to
see you know and linebacker as we talked
about a lot you know before free agency
is another issue they didn't they don't
have their
their fred warner their miles jack their
kenneth murray
you know their cam chancellor you know
kj wright they
they don't have those two linebackers in
that safety yet they got john johnson he
can fill that one role
you know they're hoping anthony walker
can do that from the colts
you know but but i think that's the one
area i look at at least be unproven
and have questions about about you know
how good they can really be
what about baker mayfield yeah what do
we really think about him right now we
were talking about
the quarterbacks of the 2018 draft class
josh allen superstar lamar jackson
superstar josh rosen
back up in san francisco sam darnold
dumped to the panthers for peanuts in
comparison to what the jets gave
up to get him where's baker mayfield sit
right now
where is he yeah i mean i
from the way the year ended i don't know
how you can't be really excited about
what we saw from baker
i mean baker really take care of the
football yes okay
but made a lot of big time plays and
throws as the year went
on and he got more confident within that
offense and everything like that
so i mean you know league wise
league wide wise mike i don't know i
mean i'm certainly going to say he's in
the top half of the nfl right now
there's no doubt about that
with the the the power in his arm you
know he fixed a few little things
mechanically last year that helped him
control the football better too
to where we didn't see the ball spray
and then
of course interception the touchdown
ratio it's a totally different
game so you know he just played a
cleaner
cleaner way of playing last year but i
think the big thing is too when
shots were there or plays were there to
be had he made them so
what do you think where i mean you're
not saying top ten but right on maybe
the edge of it what do you what do you
say trending in the right direction
my concern last year was that he was
closer to
kirk cousins than patrick mahomes yeah
on that scale of what happens when
things start to go sideways right all
due respect to kirk cousins when things
start to go sideways
it's collapse it's try to get out of the
pocket sometimes and get gobbled up
before you can get three steps away he
doesn't have the athletic ability
mayfield has enough to buy just enough
time
or also running the offense in a way
where he rarely gets in those spots
things are clicking and this gets back
to the genius of kevin stefanski and
chris remember
when we were talking about your
quarterback rankings last year one of
the things you saw with baker mayfield
was a slippage of a lot of the
fundamentals where his toes are pointing
right when when you bump up freddie
kitchen's the head coach
and the quarterbacks coach i think it
was ken zampeezy yeah remember the
offensive line coach who was the star of
hard knocks
that year that we just got exposed to
more dysfunction than we ever
with mr big belly sans said yeah yeah
right yeah
he he was the one who said hey zampeez
he's the reason mayfield had
a solid 2018 2019 he regressed
and 2020 that's when we saw the uptick
so
you still need the coaching you need to
have
people who are taking that lump of clay
and molding it into the best that it can
be and we saw the difference in the
statistics as you said the plummeting of
the interceptions
baker mayfield moving in the right
direction and i i would suspect that
stefanski who's both
worked with cousins and mayfield now
would say that mayfield has a higher
ceiling than kirk cousins i would think
so we're being candid about it
but uh yeah and that leads to the
question of when do they pay baker
mayfield
right and the better he gets the more
expensive it's going to get but these
are all problems
that the cleveland browns haven't had
yet but he do
they returned to the nfl in 1999 as the
cleveland browns so it really is amazing
i would be and this is just the way i'm
wired i'm i live in my fears way too
much
if i were a browns fan right now i would
just be waiting
for something i would just be waiting
for that hammer to fall
i would not be not you dr state of
affairs
yeah that's just i i know i would
suspect it's just a matter of time
before that boomerang comes back around
and hits me right in the face
i i i get it i guess if i was a
cleveland browns to
a fan too i'd probably probably be the
same way like
all right wait it's going too smooth
right now what's going to happen
yeah something bad is going to happen
right i i certainly can understand
that but man just from the way it looks
you know from above right now
they should be happy and feeling like
really good about their chances for the
2021 season
you know i mean baker mayfield stefanski
in that offense i think the biggest
thing stefanski did for baker mayfield
and the cleveland browns football team
is he played to the strength of their
football team which was
wait we have an overpowering dominant
offensive line
and i think between that and then going
wait we also have
maybe the best duo of running backs in
football
and they played to the running game and
that helped out
their defense which wasn't special by
any means last year
and it helped baker mayfield slowly get
accustomed to the offense
more and more comfortable until we got
to the end of the year and they get on a
run
and he can just when when he needed to
he could let it rip and make
big plays and started to show a few
moments of like
hey there's nothing there but oh baker
he he escaped out of the pocket and made
a 20-yard completion even though the
defense kind of won the play
that's that's got to be you know
uplifting for the whole team and the
organization and baker mayfield all
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports